in 2017 Tristan de Montebello had a
chance to compete in the world
championship of public speaking he was
in the semi-final round and if he won
he'd get to the top 10 of the world and
as I was watching him in the audience
give his semi-final speech a crazy thing
happen
he blanked he blanked in the middle of
his speech but he stayed in character he
maintained composure and he took a deep
breath he scanned the audience and he
waited until the next line appeared in
his head which it did which gave him the
momentum to continue pick back up and
recover beautifully so beautifully in
fact that he ended up winning the
semi-final round and got to the top 10
in the world
that's called staying in character and
if he hadn't if he instead panicked or
let his insecurities leak out by pacing
or having his voice tremble or just
going uh sorry what was I thinking right
now well that would have ruined the
whole effect for everybody and there's
no way he would have won
so what's the lesson well the lesson is
that even at the world championship
level stage people blank people lose
their train of thought and people have a
lot of inner chaos happening while
speaking but the difference is that they
have built up a habit of effective
recovery of staying in character and
maintaining composure even when things
get difficult that's what I want to talk
about right here because this is the
backbone of building confidence in your
speaking you don't have to feel
confident in order to appear confident
in fact that's kind of the most
important step in order to ultimately
feel confident it's the ability to
maintain composure even when things get
difficult or get messy what's crazy is
that Tristan had this experience happen
all the time during his training he
would go up in front of audiences he
would blink but he had the habit of
staying in character and sometimes he
would blink for so long that he'd think
I know the line's never gonna come to me
but he trained him self to pause during
those moments to breathe and to stand
with confidence looking at the audience
waiting for the line to appear so much
so that he'd have this phenomenon happen
where people would come up to him after
his speech and go that pause
that was the most powerful moment of
your speech I felt that
and that created a really interesting
idea the idea that what you feel on the
inside is not what people see on the
outside in fact sometimes it's the
opposite
chaos the turbulence the loss of words
can come across as a thoughtful
meaningful pause as long as we we are
able to maintain composure and it brings
this idea that we're not transparent
that people can't see our nervousness
unless we show them unless we have our
insecurities leak out and that's the
habit I want to talk about because I see
this all the time with anybody who wants
to improve their confidence well it's
really easy I put them in a public
speaking scenario I put them in a little
bit of a simulated pressure scenario
where they have to speak on the fly so I
know they're unprepared I know they're
probably not feeling very confident but
I try to see can you play the part can
you still speak in a way that's
confident can you own it and for most
people they can at the beginning but as
soon as they run out of something to say
or they feel like ah what they're saying
isn't coming out right there will always
be that moment where they interrupt
themselves and they go oh sorry I'm
totally blanking right now or I'm sorry
I don't know what I'm talking about or
ah this isn't making sense they have
these micro habits of shooting
themselves in the foot of telling me
I'm not feeling confident right now I'm
feeling insecure I'm feeling pressure
that's really normal but that's a habit
that we want to stop because what if we
didn't do that what if we just spoke
and maintained our composure all the way
through
well what people find out is that at the
end of the day they get perceived as
more confident
and that leads to the belief that people
are confident by default there's no
reason somebody would assume that you
aren't confident or that your speaking
has some struggle in it the only reason
they would know is if you show them and
we want to stop showing them so that
people can't assume it in the first
place and ultimately if you keep getting
the reflection hey you came across as
confident or hey that was really
interesting well then you start building
up the belief that nobody can know that
you're nervous nobody's paying attention
to that and if you're perceived as
confident well then maybe you'll start
to believe yourself to be confident
which will ultimately let you to feel
confident but it takes time and a little
bit of this is like fake it till you
make it I get it but the goal is not to
fake it always the goal is to make it
but part of the way you do that is you
show up with your best most confident
self forward I mean imagine the tennis
player who has had an injury who didn't
get a chance to practice over the last
week and still has to show up to the
match they're gonna walk out on that
Court how well if they walk out with
their shoulders slumped and with
hesitation well then that's probably how
they're going to play and that's because
confidence ultimately affects
performance that's why I'm so passionate
about this is because when I put you on
the spot or ask you a random question
and I know you're speaking on the Fly
how you show up to that question is
going to affect your performance you
could start Strong by having a strong
tone of voice by being able to jump in
with certainty or you can have
hesitation and go well I don't really
know about this topic and I haven't
thought much about it and you're
signaling little signs of feeling
uncertain about things and those signs
are silent killers of confidence because
they signal to your audience I'm
insecure and I want to show you think
about two pilots One Pilot is
experienced one is not and both are
flying in very stormy conditions so much
so there's this possibility that
something might go wrong both Pilots are
gonna feel nervous that's normal but the
experienced pilot will be able to
maintain composure in her voice and her
body language and in the way that she
perceives the situation and will be able
to act in a more controlled and calm
manner the more experienced the less
experienced pilot might feel
shaky might feel like there's there's no
place for this nervous energy to go and
so it kind of escapes through their tone
of voice or through their body language
or just through how they are expressing
themselves in the moment
the problem is not the nervousness the
problem is our willingness and desire to
leak the the nervousness to show the
insecurities in moments where we don't
have to where we could maintain
composure and choose to be confident
even though we don't feel it and that's
really important and it's probably the
most important Habit in speaking because
once we have a habit of it well then we
start to realize that all those mistakes
that we felt were worth drawing
attention to turns out they weren't
turns out most people didn't notice them
what we do is we want to have a
spotlight on them so that we can break
the tension of how uncomfortable it is
everybody saw me stumble let me address
it but when we don't address it well
people don't really pay attention to it
it's like showing up to a party wearing
a really loud shirt a really colorful
Vivid shirt that you don't feel
comfortable in but you're trying out for
Style
the Temptation is to want to address it
and say to everyone like hey yeah I'm
trying out this new style it's still I'm
still new to me I'm just trying to see
how I feel in it you want to essentially
give a justification for why you're
wearing the shirt The Confident person
wouldn't talk about the shirt at all and
they would probably be perceived as more
confident they might even get some
compliments on that shirt it's the same
idea we we have this defense mechanism
that's built into the human brain to
want to
I don't know if you've seen the movie
Eight Mile but it's like this famous
scene where before the battle rapper has
any chance to say something bad about
Eminem Eminem decides to share all his
insecurities about himself pokes fun at
himself and basically takes away
everyone else's ammo so that nobody can
poke fun at him it's that same concept
of we want to we want to be the ones
that bring ourselves down first so that
other people won't do it it's a defense
mechanism it's like
painting a picture and having your
friends come over and they see this
painting and your first Temptation might
be to go oh that's not finished or I was
just messing around with that it's to
basically say hey don't take that too
seriously because I don't want you to
judge it but when we do that we rob
people of the opportunity to make up
their own minds and what if your friend
goes whoa that's really creative or whoa
where did you buy that that's really
cool well that's interesting because
that might send a new signal to your
brain that goes huh even when I don't
feel confident about my artwork other
people perceive it as good whoa that's
strange
well it's the same thing in speaking
even when you don't feel confident about
your content or about your delivery
oftentimes people perceive it as
valuable information and as confident
delivery but we'll never be able to
create that feedback loop if we don't
give ourselves the opportunity if we
keep breaking character and essentially
telling people don't perceive this as
confident because I'm not feeling
confident
ultimately the goal is to be able to
separate our confidence from everything
from how prepared we feel from how
valuable we think the content is from
how well the speaking is going if we can
separate our confidence from that and
just learn to maintain confidence to
stay in character at all times then we
have this little kernel of control where
we give the best possible chance to
everything that we do and this applies
to speaking but it also applies to any
opportunity if you get asked to sing on
the spot and you're insecure about your
singing what would it look like to just
go for it
that's a cool mindset to just go for it
even if you feel scared or nervous or
insecure and then when you go for it no
matter how it goes don't draw attention
to oh I messed up here my girlfriend in
high school would do this all the time
she was in drama in theater and every
time I'd see her performance I'd go that
was amazing and she'd go no no no no no
this person went on stage too early this
person forgot their line and totally
messed it up and I didn't hit the notes
I wanted to hit I'm like I had no idea
you didn't have to tell me that like it
was great from my perspective
speaking feels the same way it's so
visceral we have a plan it never goes
according to plan so there's a million
reasons why we shouldn't feel proud of
it why we should feel a little bit
insecure about it but the insecurity is
okay the
point is you don't want to share it with
others you don't need to affect other
people's experiences of it because when
you don't
well people tend to assume that it was
good people tend to assume that it's
confident in fact speaking is like
background music in movies the truth is
nobody's paying attention to how you're
speaking truly they don't notice it
unless we draw attention to it like
imagine being the composer watching the
movie along with everyone else looking
at like oh how are they liking this
music how are they liking this music no
one's paying attention to the music in a
movie they're just watching the movie
but the composer is so attached to the
music that they're gonna want to be
hyper analytical it's the same in
speaking sometimes people ask me for
feedback like hey how did that go how
was my speaking and I was like I wasn't
paying attention to your speaking I was
just paying attention to what you were
saying and what you were saying was
great but having to analyze your
speaking now let me think about it no
one is paying attention to how you're
speaking except for you because you're
the one doing it and it feels messy so
staying in character is this healthy
habit of learning to detach from your
speaking of just deciding I'm gonna
maintain confidence even when things get
difficult I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
put on a confident exterior
and what you'll notice is then people
will reflect that confidence back to you
and you'll start to get feedback of you
came across confident I mean people get
this feedback all the time in the ultra
speaking courses and at first they think
oh people are just being nice to me this
is a very supportive community
but then they noticed themselves giving
that same feedback to others like hey in
that speech you were really confident I
loved what you said
the person will go what I felt super
nervous and I felt like I made no sense
to me and that's when it starts to click
we start to realize whoa
nobody really feels that confident
everybody feels like they're improvising
and yet they look so confident they
appear so poised why is that well it's
because people aren't transparent they
look Confident by default and the only
way that you might suspect that somebody
isn't feeling confident is if they show
you if they show you by leaking their
insecurities by apologizing by bringing
attention to their mistakes and by what
we call breaking character but if you
don't do that if you stay in character
as much as possible you start to
reinforce that identity of somebody who
maintains confidence you'll start to get
that reflected back at you as like whoa
that was really confident your ideas
were really valuable and you begin to
reshape your identity as somebody who is
confident and when that happens you
start to feel confident and when that
happens you stop thinking about
confidence altogether and you just show
up as yourself speaking and knowing that
no matter what happens it's gonna be
fine it's gonna be pursue received is
just fine but I know that's the
destination and if you aren't there
that's totally okay there is a path for
you that's what Ultra speaking is about
it's about learning how to get from A to
Z and we've we've built that path
through our courses the fundamentals
course probably the most important one
because by the end of that course you
will never break character in your life
that's the real focus of it is it's
putting you in a simulator it's putting
you in simulated pressure in scenarios
where there's no reason why you
shouldn't break character it's it's just
so much uncertainty but practicing the
much healthier habit of maintaining
composure being with the discomfort and
going through the Reps and appearing
confident when you're able to do that in
your practice you're going to be able to
do it in the presentation in the meeting
on the date and anywhere in between
because you realize that confidence is
totally within your control it's all
about how you recover and it's all about
how you show up and it's ultimately a
mindset and that Minds set takes time to
build but it's definitely buildable and
it's easiest to build when you build it
with other people whether that's through
a course or through a class or through
any other organization if you want to
build your confidence practice with
other people get feedback and integrate
what you're learning and you're going to
be there on your way that's what
confidence is it's the ability to show
up even when you're a little bit scared
even when you're a little bit uncertain
but owning it putting your best foot
forward and expecting success and that
success will get reflected back at you